من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل فلن تجد
له وليا
مرشدا واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك
له له الملك وله
الحمد يحيي
ويميت وهو على كل شيء
قدير واشهد ان سيدنا وعظيمنا وقائدنا
وحبيبنا محمد عبده
ورسوله وصفيه
وخليله بلغ الرساله وادى الامانه ونصح
الامه وكشف
الغمه تركنا على المحجه
البيضاء ليلها
كنهارها لا يزيغ عنها الا
هالك صلى الله عليه وعلى اله
الطيبين واصحابه اجمعين
ومن سار على نهجهم الى يوم
الدين اخص
بالذكر ابي بكر
الصديق وعمر
الفاروق وعثمان ذي
النورين وعلي
حيدر ورضي الله سبحانه
وتعالى عن السيدين الاسنين
السبطين الحسن
والحسين وعن عمي النبي
الكريمين حمزه
والعباس وعن ازواج النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم الطاهرات من الادناس
والارجاع بنات النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم زينب
قيه وام
كلثوم ولا سما قره عين
الرسول فاطمه الزهراء
البتول وعن السته البرره الذين هم تمام
العشره المبشره وعن بقيه الصحابه والقرابه
والتابعين ومن تبعهم باحسان الى يوم
الدين رضوان الله تبارك وتعالى علينا
وعليهم اجمعين
فيا عباد الله اوصيكم ونفسي المذنبه
الخاطئه بتقوى الله تعالى وطاعته ولزوم
اوامره وكثره
مخافته اطيعوا الله والرسول لعلكم ترحمون
ايها المؤمنون واعلموا عباد الله ان
التقوى شعار المؤمنين ودثار
الصالحين ووصيه الله تعالى في وفيكم
اجمعين فقد قال الله سبحانه
وتعالى وهو اصدق
القائلين يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم
مسلمون صدق الله
العظيم اما
بعد ايها
المؤمنون ما
زلنا نعيش في شهر المولد
العظيم مولد فخر
الكائنات سيدنا محمد عليه الصلاه
والسلام قال الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان الله اصطفى ادم
ونوحا وال ابراهيم وال عمران على
العالمين ذ
يه بعضها من
بعض والله سميع
عليم صدق الله
العظيم
اي ان الله تعالى اختار
هؤلاء عليهم الصلاه
والسلام
وجعلهم صفوه
العالمين بجعل النبوه
والرساله
فيهم قال علماء التفسير رحمهم الله
تعالى ان الله
تعالى اختار ادم عليه
السلام بخمس
اشياء
اولها انه سبحانه وتعالى خلقه
بيده في احسن
صوره بقدرته سبحانه
وتعالى
والثاني انه علمه الاسماء
كلها
والثالث امر الملائكه بان يسجدوا
له
والرابع اسكنه الجنه
والخامس جعله ابا
للبشر وسببا في وجود
الخليقه كما اختار الله سبحانه
وتعالى نوحا عليه
السلام بخمسه
اشياء
اولها انه
جعله ابا البشر ايضا
لان الناس
كلهم غرقوا وصار
ذريته هم
الباقين
والثاني انه اطال
عمره فقد عاش الف سنه الا 50
عاما
ويقال طوبى لمن طال
عمره وحسن
عمله
طوبى لمن طال
عمره وحسن
عمله
الثالث انه استجاب دعائه سبحانه وتعالى
على
الكافرين وكذلك استجاب الله سبحانه وتعالى
دعاء
للمؤمنين اما
الرابع انه حمله على
السفينه
والخامس انه كان
اول من نسخ
الشرائع وكان قبل ذلك لم يحرم تزويج
الخالات
والعمات وقد اختار الله
تعالى ابراهيم بخمسه اشياء
ايضا
اولها انه جعله ابا
الانبياء لانه روي انه خرج من صلبه اي من
صلب ابراهيم عليه السلام الف نبي من
زمانه الى زمن النبي محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الثاني اتخذه الله
خليلا
والثالث انه انجاه من
النار
والرابع انه جعله اماما
للناس
والخامس انه ابتلاه
بالكلمات
فوفقه حتى اتمه
ه واذ ابتلى ابراهيم ربه
بكلمات فتاب
عليه انه هو التواب
الرحيم ثم قال سبحانه
وتعالى في هذه
السوره ان الله اصطفى
ادم
ونوحا وال ابراهيم
وال
عمران وال عمران فان كان عمران ابا موسى
وهارون فالله سبحانه وتعالى اختارهما على
العالمين حيث بعث على قومه المن
والسلوى وذلك لم يكن لاحد من الانبياء في
العالم
وان كان ابا
مريم
عمران فانه اصطفى له مريم بولاده عيسى
بغير
اب ولم يكن ذلك لاحد في العالم ايضا سوى
سيدنا
ادم
وزوجه
حواء عليهما
السلام ايها المؤمنون
وقد من الله سبحانه
وتعالى على البشريه
جمعا بارسال رسوله
الكريم محمد بن عبد
الله صلى الله عليه واله وصحبه
وسلم
لينقلها من ذل عباده
المخلوق الى عز طاعه الخالق جل وعلا
ومن الظلم
والجور وسفك
الدماء الى ساحه العدل والامن والاطمئنان
من الفرقه
والاختلاف الى الاجتماع
والائتلاف من التعاون على الاثم
والعدوان الى التعاون على البر
والتقوى من الى الامر بالمنكر والنهي عن
المعروف الى الامر
بالمعروف والنهي عن
المنكر من الغش
والخيانه الى النصح
والامانه من الجزع
والهلع والاعتراض على قضاء الله الى الصبر
والثبات والرضا بما قدره الله وقضاه
وفي
الجمله من كل ضار عاجلا
واجلا الى كل نافع في الحال
والمال وقد ارشد سبحانه الى شكره على
ذلك
بعبادته وحده لا شريك
له وهذا في قوله سبحانه
وتعالى يلاف قريش
ايلافهم رحله الشتاء
والصيف
فليعبدوا رب هذا
البيت الذي اطعمهم من جوع وامنهم من
خوف ان هؤلاء رسل
وانبياء هم صفوه
الخلق
فاما سيدنا محمد
صلى الله عليه
وسلم فقد جازت
مرتبته
الاصطفاء
لانه
حبيب
ورحمه قال
تعالى وما
ارسلناك الا رحمه
للعالمين فالرسل والانبياء
خلقوا للرحمه
وسيدنا محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم خلق بنفسه
رحمه فلذلك
صار عليه الصلاه والسلام
امانا للخلق
اجمعين لما بعثه الله تعالى امن امن الخلق
العذاب الى نفخه
الصور وسائر
الانبياء لم يحلوا هذا المحل
ولذلك قال عليه الصلاه
والسلام انما ان رحمه
مهداه يخبر صلى الله عليه واله وصحبه وسلم
انه
بنفسه رحمه للخلق من
الله
وقوله عليه الصلاه والسلام مهدات اي هديه
من الله
للخلق اللهم صل على سيدنا
محمد الذي ارسله الله رحمه
للعالمين اللهم جملنا بالعافيه
واحشرنا مع من جعلته رحمه
للعالمين صلى الله عليه واله وصحبه وسلم
ادعوا الله وانتم موقنون
بالاجابه ‏l